i will press the button
[Music]
why do i know that
i know i know that
hot
hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to inscription apparently
this game is not what it seems or maybe
it's exactly what it seems because it
seems to be an escape room card game and
i don't know what that's about
so let's find out
[Music]
oh i get it
well i can't i can't do it right there
oh all right seems good i can't
continue i don't
this is all part of the trick isn't it
you want me to say continue because you
think that there's something there but
there's not i've never played this game
before in my life i would never test out
a game before i would actually record it
what do you think i want to actually
have skill going into this no
oh my god
another challenger it has been ages wow
perhaps you have forgotten how this game
is played allow me to remind you
[Music]
ah play the squirrel card should i
okay
now play your stoat oh i'm gonna play my
stoad all right
just you wait till i play my s
stoats cost one blood sacrifices must be
made
yeah
oh an honorable death play the stoked
okay
state
[Music]
wolves require two sacrifices you don't
have enough
ring the bell to end your turn and
commence combat
your stone stands unopposed i know it's
what i'm so proud about my stoat
the number on the bottom left is the
attack power of one
what happened
your stoke dealt me one damage i added
it to the
scale you win if you tip my side all the
way down
oh
like this nice hand
is that a glove with a fingernail or is
that just your hand i'm not
sure my turn
your stoat stands in the way of my
coyote
my coyote dealt two damage to your stoat
that means your stoat's health is too
less
if a creature's health reaches zero it
dies
your turn again
you may draw from your deck or you may
draw a square roll i think i'll draw a
square a roll but i only have one card
left in my deck what could it be
i might as well find out
how reckless of me
you're right
very reckless initiate combat
take that
because you are learning i will pass
you're you've drawn all the creatures
from your deck a squirrel is your only
choice
okay
i play squirrel
i've done it
and i play wolf
hey
its suffering was real but you will see
it again what was that about the thing
that there was text that was going on
what is underneath that
what is going on underneath with that
squirrel
i don't like the pulsating i don't like
the throbbing i don't oh goodbye
wolf time
all right
i feel i kind of made a river snapper i
guess
the wolf's pretty good too
take that
ha ha
three damage stealth three weights on
the scale
uh-huh
yes
that's that's pretty
pretty
bad playing you know
squirrel
all right
take that
i win
you've won this match
thank you
it won't all be so easy
let me recall your story oh thank you my
story you know it's so much better than
i do
oh yes
oh
you were lost deep in the forest
a single path revealed itself
two denizens of the forest approached
you tentatively
the caustic adder
damage from its poison bite is always
lethal
the undying cat
sacrificing the poor beast does not kill
it
only one may grace your paltry deck
interesting so i could either have an
adder that is always deadly when it hits
does that
does that count for players as well i
doubt it because it says one so it can
kill any enemy i think i'd rather have
the undying cap but it does look like
they can attack that but maybe the
turtle is one of those things where it
has to attack the defending creature
which if i had a turtle it can help out
a lot
i'll take the cat i like cats anyway
another creature joins your caravan some
of the creatures of the forest seemed
willing to follow you
you came across an abandoned sack
you found a squirrel in a bottle
break in case of emergency
and have a second
another useful implement i'll allow you
to dip the scales with it
do i have to pull my own teeth three is
as much
as you can carry
okay thank you
oh you were
ambushed while crossing some rough
terrain
you sacrificed me while i was sleeping
it was the right play i get it maybe
you'll help me
uh
play along for now
okay you got it
you may now see my moves ahead of time
why
so i need
to sacrifice
interesting wolf cubba interesting very
interesting very interesting
did i remind you your items may help no
no no no i don't need them i'm gonna
play my
cat
take that cat cat was fat i put the cat
in the hat
oh that's helpful hmm
interesting
so
wham and oh
here we go
okay
you cannot draw your card on your first
turn okay anyway clock lunk
what an interesting game hey my balder
mind the ambitious wolf cub it ages
swiftly
okay
i'll take uh this
nice i guess i should have put it over
there but maybe i should have put the
big honker over there what are you gonna
do a bat is a bat fly and i can't hit
the bat can i not hit the bat with my
cat is the cat going to hit my bat is
the best gonna hit my cat is the wolf
gonna hit my boulder
what if i do emergencies no save it who
needs it on the first turn nobody not me
devil
an airborne bat flies over creatures to
attack directly well that's not good
ow
well hold on about that
hold on a minute there cause watch this
then i'm gonna play the wolf by going
yeah yeah put it right there
easy peasy done and done
super easy
take that
and one oh
oh yeah well get ready to go wolf to
wolf and i'm going to get the first
attack so suck eggs oh wait a minute
i'mma kill you stoke sorry bud
okay hang on hold on
wow seriously yep
pretty seriously i'm just gonna go ahead
and finish oh wait no i would have been
fine i'm gonna kill your wolf anyway i
guess i didn't need to do that oh yes i
did i guess oh yeah that was a bad play
oh
it was good play
i'm the best
take one of these
and take one of these and one of these
the squirrel this cat was the best move
this cat was the right move this cat was
good move this count was a good move
take that put your teeth all gone you
prevailed
and trekked onwards past the now bloody
terrain i guess it would yeah i guess it
would have been what is going on here by
the way why do i see creepy shadows
pulsing in and out such as the fire
light
anyway i'm gonna go now
oh boy i get to build my deck
the young wolf cub it grows into a wolf
after a single turn hey that cost blood
yours didn't cost
blood the meek sparrow an inexpensive if
feeble flying creature i guess i'm
i'll attack your hit points directly
i'll do sparrow
i like the idea of flying
oh what is that
oh you stumbled into some strange stones
in the mist
did i
you were compelled to choose a worthy
sacrifice
one that will be
lost forever
oh oh oh but i just got it but i just
i'm not going to get rid of my cat not
for some stupid bird when it's not even
a bat i gotta get my cat got a hat for
my cat
put a hat on my cat
you know my lap it will sadness get away
well i guess that's
you looked upon your menagerie and
selected a healthy host
pick me i like the sound of that
all right
all right yeah absorb that power you're
gonna be a flying stoat now
hi yeah
what an honor
hey
a ghastly spectacle but the soul of the
sparrow now lives
in the stoughton oh i could have made it
an immortal stone that would have i
didn't know that's
flying's kind of cool though flying
stoad is pretty cool
but an immortal stout would have been
even better
half-lifestyle it's fine it's fine it's
all good oh but i want the flying straw
but i want them more oh god it inscribes
my canine cords with the airborne sigil
hey
well that's
he's completely insane you see that
right
no care for the rules pathetic really
enough
only keeps me around watch me suffer
all right
hiya
and then haiyah take that
back on the board oh yeah you are
hi coyote oh my totem has granted my
coyote the power of flight
ow
hold on now
i guess i should have
oh but
duh but it's oh but it could have been
oh but that could have been oh
oh can i go back
no i gotta move forward i gotta always
press forward it can change
well i'm gonna die
unless i sacrifice that stoat which i
could have that could have been an
immortal cat and it would have been
totally cool and chill and tight
and dope
no i didn't mean to do that
i did not meet okay well i guess oh game
over
well i didn't i didn't mean to do that i
didn't mean to i've yep
using this as a learning opportunity may
be the only way to mitigate my
disappointment
get up get up from the table what excuse
me i'm sorry
fetch me the candlestick from atop the
barrel beside the
what
[Music]
no
how about
i can't use that right no i cannot
hello my friend
okay
[Music]
well you know hang on
oh
hello
yeah
[Music]
ah okay
now sit back down
okay
will do champ thanks pal didn't really
illuminate anything very much
let me explain something to you
that was one of the two mistakes you can
make here
if you make another i'm gonna sacrifice
you
no
where were we
okay well that's a little bit um
don't know about that one
what have we got a wolf a vicious
contender ah river snapper nearly
impenetrable and an adder
well what is with those
what's the mushies all about look at the
adder i guess i see i could either do a
camp or i could do a i'm gonna make my
stoat immortal
i shall make my stoat immortal
oh i can't make my stode immortal what
if i make my stote poison it what if i
make my cat poisonous
can i do that
whoo would it replace
its infinitiness
i have a funny feeling it's not gonna
compound it i have a funny feeling it's
going to
be rid of it only one way to find out
i'm playing a new game here here we go
[Music]
oh
it's both it's a poisonous cat i don't
know if it can even attack can it
maybe that was a bad idea
any grand fur all right whatever grant
fur oh it blocks uh it blocks uh
floaties
all right cat
you're gonna
there you go there you go buddy all
right let's see what else we got here
can't draw blood from a grand fur you'll
need something else
all right no i don't
ah maybe i should have put the cap over
there that really hurt
that hurt like a lot i
i should have i didn't i didn't
okay
okay this will buy me a turn
can i move them once i play them no i
guess i can't all right i could do an
emergency squirrel i didn't know that i
was going to need it right away
but let's see what happens
god i really should put that unless you
with the cat there i guess
maybe a poisonous cat was like the
dumbest thing i could possibly have done
it does seem like it was the dumbest
thing that i could have possibly done
try that
yeah take some of that
oh well don't you worry about a thing
because
there's a way out for both of us
it's somewhere in this foul cabin
be silent or i'll tear you to france
this spot you sure oh yeah
dead sure
i'm so sure
oh
all right time to win this easy peasy
ding-dong bam i
you win
suck ass ass
uh i guess i already have items because
i don't use anything that anyone ever
gives me
also what was that about the the
something about this foul cabin
the conniving raven a blight upon the
skies
the monstrous grizzly its form speaks
enough of its efficacy
okay
well
this is delightful i will take this into
consideration
and i will get the grizzly what does the
fire do
oh you came across a small group of
survivors faces shrunken from starvation
they huddled around the campfire
they looked upon your group of creatures
and beckoned
come
warm one of your creatures by the fire
once said moment by the fire
that will enhance its power said another
you notice one of the survivors wiping
drool
from the mouth i don't think it's gonna
enhance its
power hmm yeah i don't know if it'll
enhance his power
i don't think it's gonna be enhancing
its power
i'm pretty sure
i have a bad feeling about doing that i
think that would i it
it's so clearly not good
it's so clearly ungood but the wolf in
there
plus
the fire warmed the poor wolf enhancing
its power oh it did one of the survivors
reached towards it another gnashed their
teeth
without a word you pulled the wolf away
from the fire and left oh i could have
enhanced my
my my stoat
damn it well damn it
turns out i don't
what is that supposed to be
the trees seemed to close in around you
as a chillmast descended
in the distance you could hear the
clinking of metal and stone
a hobbled figure stood in your
path oh hi oh hi huh yeah
twas the prospector
[Applause]
he's doing the prospector again easy
boss the mule's key
the mules key
the mules pack mule i don't even know
what that means
prospector
[Laughter]
do i gotta kill it or what do i gotta do
with it i don't know well let's go ahead
and get some business underway let's go
ahead and do one of these
take that
what what did you just what did you pack
mule what did you pack mule what did you
pack muhlinize
damn it i wanted my cat damn it where's
my cat
damn it emergency squirrel emergency
squirrel
take one of these
and another cause why not
because i'm bad at this game which one
of these is my big wolf
ah yes
[Music]
take one of these and i'm gonna put it
there because i don't care
because i'm worried more about hitting
him than i am yeah there we go there we
go i'm not scared of that coyote if i
can just keep hitting him oh my boulder
cat
grizzly god damn it well i guess i'm
going to finish this anyway
game's over
i hope you didn't think it would be that
easy
okay
there's gold in them cards
oh what oh
what
struck gold wha what what happened i'm
confused am confused what is with the
goat why
i have a feeling these are just going to
kill my cat alright let's just see what
happens
how ow
okay
oh
that didn't seem good
why did that shake i don't like that
i don't like that i don't have anything
else do i
well looks like it's game over for me
there goes my cat and there goes my life
oh boy
well it's been fun
no more gold for oh god oh god oh my god
well that just goes to show you um
you aren't dead yet
this isn't purgatory
though you may think of it that way
before you expire i must ask you a favor
i would like memento
your very own death card
it's quite plain that the moment isn't
we will
work together to amend that
i want this to be the perfect memento of
you
here's some cards from your mediocre
deck
we can put them to good use
please choose a card to draw the cost
from
uh let's go big cost cause i three blood
from the grizzly i'm an expensive lad
the power and health oh
yeah two power two health
the sigils oh well i guess i should have
made it cheaper then
since you'll have many lives
i said you love a gift of death from the
cat oh that's a nice card
i never did ask you your name call me
markiplier
way too expensive but too complicated
always on the attack there's about one
final manner the portrait
aha hey
oh all right
i think i blinked
here we go again hi
another
challenger perhaps it is time
perhaps you can understand bones
bones
resourceful opossum costs two bones
you get a bone when one of your
creatures perishes for any reason oh
that's nice
hi yeah
and what is that a rattler a rattler you
got it take that
one bone for me
from the death of your creature you've
gained a bone
you'll not lose this until it is spent
where the battle ends
okay thank you
[Music]
that's it then
no it's going to kill that
ah well easy come easy go
what are you
bullfrog flight protection because it
can nab it out of the sky
nice i'm going to play this take one of
those
and then one of these
y'all
i guess i could wait until i get the
wolf here that's fine
hey
bam easy done win it
i win
take that
and then take this
ha yeah
i'm brutal of you you've only more
damage than you needed to win
however in my game such feats are
rewarded
to be precise a tooth to keep for each
extra damage dealt
the trapper may be interested in your
spoils
i don't know who the trapper is who's
the trap man i forgot your figurine
go up and fetch it for me
okay well
it's beside the safe okay i will do boss
where's the trapper oh
okay hey buddy hi oopsies hey buddy how
you doing good to see you again i'm back
now
how do i sit down there we go let us
continue
let us
lettuce
meeker coyote what did you expect for
only four bones
nefarious rattler a brittle creature
once passes monsters fangs
the unkillable cockroach it returns to
your hand after dying
all of them require bones i don't have
that many bones i'll do the cockroach i
like things that are unkillable
all right cool you know you're free to
get up again
to keep your
blood flowing
i'm good bro i'm good unless no am i
good i am no tyrant you may stand
whenever the map is unrolled
it allows me time to plan your next
encounter
but do keep your hands off my
possessions
okay buddy okay pal all right okay all
right you get you oh wow
oh i've absorbed all what was that
oh
huh i want to meet the bone lord boy
there's a lot of those pliers did i hear
pliers
anyway whatever i already have those
oh lovely wolf what lovely
did i snuff that out i didn't mean to
snuff that was that your life i hope it
was
just kidding
some bone tokens for a rainy night
a rock may get you out of a hard place
choose one
oh
um
i um choose a rock i choose the rock
feeling overburdened enough with the
three items you carried on
okay
ah
good what is that
a wolf cub
[Laughter]
take that
yeah nice try
hmm
interesting
oh
wow
that didn't go as planned
all right
here we go that thing's about to go
bye-bye that thing's about to go bye-bye
watch this huh yeah
alpha more like not that
take
this looks like you got nothing left to
do
are you smart or something he usually
doesn't even
bother teaching about bones
all right here's a tip
i saw a past victim
writing a passcode
in the rulebook
interesting
do tell
that's what you get
total miss play you don't know what miss
you shut your mouth
i wanted to do some over damage
excellent i am the best what was that
about in the rulebook
270.
i don't know how i missed that
interesting
hey
oh hello
i was sure if i would ever escape that
iron crypt it's
it's the stone around
the stunted wolf
this madness must end
put that away
i got a key i know what a key's for i'm
touching your stuff and there's nothing
you can do about it buddy
there's not a thing you can do what do
you think about that a-hole
what do you think about that dill weed
yeah you better be afraid
with your long grabby hands what is this
supposed to be
interesting
oh two or three correct
oh well that was easy
ah stink i forgot that i put that there
very well
you may add it to your deck and i'll
deal you one ever so often
well thank you thank you
ah interesting
hey man i'm good at that apparently
formidable creatures those ants very
well i will add them to your deck and
make them available for future
challenges
okay thank you
god damn i'm good at this i don't even
remotely know how how to do any of this
[Music]
i see it's okay so i
i get it now i understand what it is
this is a game board i got that it's
like so you're trying to attack and do
five damage in one turn that's what
you're trying to do
[Music]
there there that's what it was it was
like for some reason i felt like all the
cards had to be in the center to be
valid but i forgot that if you just like
kick them off the other side then it'll
just
kill things
curious
and the ants what i didn't recognize
about the ants was the more ants on the
board they power each other up i don't
know what that cage dog was all about so
with this one i don't know what these
power up signs mean i think it means
like the attack is split that way in
that way
so like this does one hit there one hit
there one hit there i should do a hit
there
this should do three damage right there
i don't know why it's not
and these can't move so that makes that
actually kind of easier you just know
those are going to be there
i don't know what these do
something about this like causes a power
up i don't know why
i could look in the rule book but you
know that'd be too much work oh there we
go never mind i got it
without having met
her
this wood carving is meaningless
in time you will understand his power
okay whatever i understand this game a
little better now which is awfully good
for me it's gonna help me kick your ass
so get ready to get your ass kicked i'm
gonna kick your ass i'm gonna go away
it's me wow that's a good card i wish i
didn't make it so goddamn expensive why
did i do that i'm an idiot i don't know
the bountiful war and spawns of rabbit
when it is played that's good
the venerable alpha its courage
emboldens the creatures that stand by
outside okay i want the rabbit sex
dungeon i want the rabbit multiplication
studio and i'm gonna apply that nonsense
to something i've got
so it's like infinite
the choice is yours i don't know what
the stink means
what if i do infinite wrath
if i wait it already has infinite ants
it doesn't need more or does it
what if i put
the ants on the rabbit would i put the
rabbit on the answer that more if
would that work well let me let me just
see if i can
i'll go hey you shut up infinite skinks
not the worst idea all right you go
skink you go skinky
you skinky kinky with your infinite
rabbits
yeah all right
look at that you're gonna have so many
rabbits
all right i don't know what that is but
that looks like kind of a boss my boss i
want to kick the ass off i'm gonna kick
your ass
yeah get ready i'm gonna kill oh
what ain't good
you again
indeed our friend freed me
well i basically told them how to do it
you got a plan
we have another friend here you gotta be
i wouldn't call him friend
but
i suppose we are in deep this time
whatever you say man whatever you say
what are you gonna do coyotes
coyotes
like stoop and uh stoop boats well i'm
not gonna do it right away so i'm gonna
do a squirrel
i'm gonna get mr stoat man i'm gonna i'm
gonna have him behind this stump because
he's gonna be working up a storm over
here
fine
rabbit look at that
hell yeah what does the stink do i don't
know what the stink do i don't know
whatever rabbit i'm gonna get a bullfrog
it's not gonna do uh it's not gonna do
much good on this turn now whatever
let's just go for it it's going to just
die in the next one stink bog i don't
know what the stink do
back in the game
you sure are guys you sure are ha yeah
take that
oh
oh whoa
ow
all right
caged wolf what happens if you
what happens if the caged wolf gets out
well i can't play it yet so
yeah
where's my rabbit where's my free rabbit
where's my free rabbit don't i get a
rabbit stoat man don't aren't i supposed
to get a rabbit she's supposed to give
me
i thought i was supposed to get a rabbit
i don't know work her aunt oh that's not
good that's not what we want i don't
have any ants oh boy
bye stinky
oh this isn't good
emergency squirrel no not
yet why did that tree have a bone
why'd that tree have a bone
all right i sure do have a lot of
useless cards okay i gotta start doing
some damage here i thought you were
supposed to give infinite bunnies i
thought that was a whole idea so you
just endlessly popped out bunnies like
nobody's business all right it's
emergency squirrel time
okay i got a lot of bones
take that ow
well
breathing
ant queen well that would have been
great if i didn't just kill my aunt
oh god damn it oh
oh
i'll wait till next turn because we're
at an impasse
all right whatever
um buh
i'll keep drawing
i see the way this is going
i concede
you may accept my surrender
we may finish this match the slow way no
no no no no i got it i got it i got you
i got you you should
you shush your shush
and i'll shush it for you
you know
you will you you shishman's your
shishmans
shish shish shish hang on i got some
good cards here i thought so i knew it i
knew i had good cards in here now watch
this magic um
i got some mumbo jumbo going on here
you're gonna love the mumbo and the
jumbo
huh yeah
you ain't so flighty now
that's what i thought that's what i
thought that's what i thought what else
do i get your cockroach well i don't
exactly have what i need for that
but i could
skink it up and then i could do a
cockroach i forgot i didn't realize that
i could actually attack those things so
that was my bad that was my bad on that
take one of these
[Music]
the weed
is that a trap that looks like a trap i
don't like the trap is that a trap i
don't like the trap i'm like oh
you were stumped along the way by a
trapper looking to liquidate his pelts
there was something uncanny about his
appearance
but you were quickly distracted by his
wares
oh
care to look at me pelts
not sure about that one
take a pelt free pre-charge
okay see the quality
yeah real qualitatious golden belt wow
you're leaving already please consider
me pelts
why i hadn't i didn't know that meant i
was going already i have
thief
i'm not a hundred percent sure what a
belt what a peltier oh
is it like a defense
wait what happened to my
wanted the pill
you'll need more teeth for that one
thanks for your business
thank you
the man assured you of the value of the
belts
they appear to be useful useless in a
fight
but he mentioned that the traitor
further down the path would reward you
for them
okay cool
ah
okay all right another boulder bones
take the bones i got the bones this
game's fun by the way i've kind of been
really into it just like this i love
anything with a deep style all right
well let's get me
me stowed out here
oh yeah
take this
keep me alive
i'll do what i want to do you shush your
mouth
turn over
how y'all
got those coyotes do a lot of damage i
don't like how much damage those coyotes
do
right okay all right i'm gonna do this
the right way hey yeah
excellent uh
well
not exactly what i was hoping for but
watch this move
take one of these
and i'm going to put
i've got this take this and this
and put this here and then take one of
these and put that there
i got you and maybe i should put
the wolf pelt over there no then i
wouldn't be able to do anything about it
of course this is the right move
take one of these
oh
ow
god i'm dead i'm doomed
oh i'm doomed
i'm doomed
well that's
kind of helpful
that's not helpful that's not helpful at
all uh
boulder i'll give that a give this wolf
cup something to think about
well that was a good move everybody that
was a good move
all right
oh yeah
it went underwater i don't know what
that means i guess i can't attack it
well
this kind of sucks having my deck filled
up with all these specialty cards right
at the beginning kind of made it a
little bit more difficult because mom
now my deck is completely uh yeah it has
a problem now my deck is completely
arbitrary ah yank them my two thumbs
well-earned point of damage i didn't
think you would really do
well you thought wrong i'm here to win
although that might not be enough no
idea
ow
uncaged the menagerie hey look it did
work what was that
it did it worked
it worked
it worked but i'm still kind of screwed
because everything costs two so strange
why can't i remember his name
i believe
i lost some of my memory
in the flesh
yeah that flash though it's pretty uh
pretty intense okay if i don't do
anything i'm gonna die here i'll play
you right
there
oh the stink lowers its damage
you got some big stink man
you got big stink energy
all right let's do this ha ha
ha
idiot oh
well
so far so good
all according to plan
god i wish i had something i could
actually play you have me here i
surrender i take it i take
you're right i had you you
you sack a crap
i had you on the ropes i really did you
you didn't stand a chance really
honorable you to do that really
honorable you to do that
oh it's the right thing to do is the
right thing to do a flighty elk it moves
after attacking
a sparrow
wearing oh god another one of you what
is it again when a card bearing the
sigil is played a rabbit is created in
your hand a rabbit is defined well great
that's great what use was that
i thought that was a lot more useful
i'd pick the rabbit hole
all right get ready i'm gonna give
something else rabbit power
something else is gonna get rabid power
now
just you wait i don't know what but
something something with one i need
something with one because that way i
can get more out of it
something cheap something cheap i knew i
just just cause i only uh you get it
you're fine it's fine you get it you
stink man
rabbit hole
rabbit it up no the other way around
damn
[Music]
oh wait a minute what the hell was that
all about my boss battled their
high-stakes test of your aptitude with
one flame you will either overcome them
or die fear not i'll let you keep the
smoke
oh this it's the smoke hi okay well this
doesn't seem fair
the incessant clank clank clanking
reverberated between your ears
the bath head was blocked by a grotesque
figure
[Music]
yeah it's the prospector again
again
yeah okay
all right listen guys
i don't know this i'm about to bring the
smoke
i'm about to bring the smoke okay this
is not how i thought this was gonna go
down
but alas here we are okay what are you
doing coyote there
okay so something about the pack mule
they said the pack meal was key so i
need to put something
at i need to attack the pack mule that's
what i got to do
i wonder can you keep blood tokens can
you get extra blood i guess not you just
need to keep it as a
as a thing
the smoke
so many bones so many bones you gotta
separate the bones from your meat
otherwise
you're gonna get chaos
all right
here we go we've got this how do we got
it i'm yeah we got this watch this got
this
got this and then watch this
watch me got this oh well that's not
good for my stove all right watch me got
this cause i got this and i'm gonna get
a good watch of this
take this rabbit
and a skink
and then that's it
out
oh the pack mule moves left oh
interesting i did not know that about
the back mule
interesting rabbit pelt that's again
very unhelpful i didn't why did i get
these uh because they probably are worth
more when we go through it if we get up
the road which is what we're gonna do
we gotta get it and we're gonna get a
good
let's go ahead and get the ant queen out
there let's see what it does i don't
know what it's going to do but i feel
good about having an ant queen out here
somehow
mole i don't like that let's do this
blam blam get it in there
power numbers dance creed oh if i had
one more i'd be able to play it well god
damn it oh wait no that came with the
thing right we're good
hiya pick that oh
that's not good
oh yes yes yes yes
excellent and then i can play the worker
hand right there
oh yes yes yes
got a lot of bones
oh but then he's gonna oh he's gonna
kill my oh he's gonna kill them god damn
it i should have saved that well i
didn't i didn't have a chance to save
that how could i have saved anything i
didn't even have anything to save
wolf yeah that would be useful but my
guys are gonna die so i might as well
just let it be
oh well that went well hey
all right what about this
what about one of these moves ha ha take
that and that and put that there
bam
ow oh ow
i'm gonna kill the wolf or the pad the
mule i'm gonna kill the mule i'm gonna
kill them you i'm about to kill the mule
let's hope something with bones yes yes
it's something with bones i have a lot
of bones well i might as well kill that
wolf cup
might as well oh yeah bam boom what did
i get
[Music]
that's what you get buddy that's what
you get oh what did i get mantis ha ha
oh wolfie and coyote
all right
so i'm gonna prep by just i'm gonna
get some squirrels or some
okay
interesting squirrel okay cool
so this next one he's gonna turn all my
things to gold
or there's gold in them dar
there's golden damn cards ever heard
oh
are yous unfortunately the cockroach
how
cold has the gold
well that's unfortunate of how
i don't really have a methodology to get
oh
wait a minute oh now there's things in
the way
all right whatever i guess i just got to
do the coyote yeah that's good don't get
ahead of yourself you need to draw a
card first sorry whatever i'll draw a
card fine god's my wolf belt
right coyote there
all right let's do this
one of those you're done
you're get them
[Laughter]
i'm so sorry for you
looks like this is
the road
oh
i think that maybe you ain't gonna feel
too good after this one
wash some of this
[Music]
and then i'll wash
one of these yeah yeah yeah
you thought i was done with that no
no way
cause i got another cockroach right
there
thank you for opening yourself up for
that thank you for that
i did it ate my ass prospector
oh
allow me to lay your cancels once more
i won't be killing you quite yet
thanks bud
[Music]
thanks pal you're the first in a while
to overcome a boss
as a reward you are granted an
opportunity to select
a rare card
choose
[Music]
this level of brutus strength needs no
explanation
well any big damage card can just be
killed by a snake so that's not very
cool long elk what
i have no words for this freak of nature
what do you what do you mean a long elk
the hell is that
what am i looking at is this all just
one long elk
the ultimate defense
okay
so he intentionally stands in the way i
mean that's a pretty good card now
that's a card right there that's i
picked that one
hell yeah
mole man it is wow with the sound of the
prospector's pickaxe still ringing in
your ears you continued onwards
did i hm
the rank smell of rotten mold permeated
their humid air
every step forward was answered by some
near my slipper slither
you'd fit cautiously into
the wetlands
or i will in the next episode of this
game because i am out of time for this
one but thank you everybody so much for
watching i am super into this game
this is fascinating i mean it's a fun
card game by itself but also just like
the the idea of there being this
like
whole
cabin experience is crazy but i love it
so
thank you everybody so much for watching
let me know what you thought down in the
comments below and as always we'll see
you
in the next video
bye-bye
[Music]
you